Hello and welcome, I'm James Murphy and today
we're talking about the md5 hashing algorithm.
md5 stands for "message digest 5" and what
it does is it takes in a message and outputs
a summary, called the "digest", of the message.
Change the message by even one character and
the digest is supposed to be completely different.
The message can be any length but the digest
will always be exactly 128 bits, which we
think of as four 32-bit integers.
md5 is what's called a "hash function", which
really just means it takes messages of any
length to a fixed-length.
But md5 wasn't intended to just be a hash
function, it was intended to be a secure hash
function.
Among other things, you aren't supposed to
be able to find inputs with a given hash,
or even two inputs with the same hash.
Unfortunately, md5 is not a secure hash function.
It's completely broken for cryptographic use,
but it's still important from a historical
perspective, so let's take a look at it, see
an implementation of it, and then discuss
some real-world attacks against it.
But before we do, do you know who is not going
to use the broken hash function like md5?
Today's sponsor, Hostinger.
Try Hostinger's premium shared hosting plan,
which has 99.9% guaranteed uptime, one free
domain and free SSL certificate, and a 30-day
money-back guarantee.
Use coupon code MCODING in all caps at checkout
to get up to 91% off on all yearly plans.
Okay so let's just dive into the code.
What I have here is an implementation of the
md5 algorithm.
The first thing that we need to do is decide
what does md5 take in and what does it spit
out.
So what I decided is that we're taking in
bytes and we're spitting out bytes.
The way that we're going to do this is basically
we make a state object which is going to keep
track of all the information of the algorithm,
we feed in whatever bytes that we have and
then we're going to have to do some finalization.
And the reason for this is because md5 works
on blocks that are 512 bits long, 64 bytes,
so if your input string was not the correct
length that it has to get padded,
and that's going to happen in this finalization
step.
So down here I have basically the same thing,
but instead I'm directly passing in a file
handle.
We see that the md5 state object is keeping
track of four things, the most important one
is this state variable.
At the end, the state is going to be what
is ultimately made into the digest.
The way that works is it operates on chunks
of 512 bits at a time, so the first thing
is, of course, you need to take in exactly
64 bytes,
and then we may convert those bytes to integers.
So we take the whole chunk and we convert
64 bytes into 16 integers.
Then we start with the process of updating
the state.
So we have four variables, a b c d, that make
up our state variable then we're going to
go through 64 times and basically mix in the
message in a particular way.
So the general way that this works is for
each of the 64 steps there is a mixer for
that step.
It's going to mix up bits and then we're also
going to mix up which of the bytes that we
use from the message.
The 64 steps of the algorithm are split into
four rounds of 16.
In the first round we use the F mixer, in
the second-round we use the G mixer, third-round
H mixer, fourth round I mixer.
So this mixer_for_step whatever is going to
just tell you which of the F G H I is going
to be used for that step in the algorithm.
Similarly we're not going to read the message
in order, and so in the first round you read
the 16 integers in this order,
in the second round we read it in a different
order, and so we take the mixer for a given
step and we take the index which integer do
we want to read from the message at each step,
we just put both of those into big list so
that for every step we know which int we're
supposed to be reading out of this array,
and which mixing function we're supposed to
use.
So for all 64 steps we pick the correct mixer,
we pick the correct index for the message
that we're supposed to be using, and then
we just use this formula.
We take a, and then we throw b, c, and d in
with the mixer and then add that in, and then
we add the message at the specified index
in, and then we add in this sine randomness.
This is just another thing that's just thrown
in just because the algorithm says to.
Okay so back to the main loop.
We mix our bits, we rotate our bits, then
we add a to b and then we rotate.
We take a b c d and you can see we take the
d and we put it in the front here so that
we have d a b c.
That's all there is to it. After we mixed
all of our bits up in this way 64 times,
then whatever our state variables are, now
we add them to what they were at the beginning.
So how do we ensure that we actually do this
for every 512 bits in the message?
Well that's what the process function is for.
So here's what we do in a loop:
We try to read however many bytes it takes
to fill up our buffer and make a full block_size
number of bytes.
If our buffer was empty before and then I
read in a full block size, then I just go
ahead and call compress on the buffer and
then increase the length.
Otherwise I already had some bytes in my buffer
or I didn't read enough bytes in order to
fill up the buffer.
So what I do in that case is I note that,
you know, I've now filled up more bytes, and
if I filled up, now, enough to do a compression,
if I filled up the whole buffer,
then I go ahead and compress and increase
the length and then set the number of filled
bytes back to zero.
Otherwise I still haven't read enough bytes
in order to do another compression, so I just
keep reading bytes until I get to the end
of the stream.
But what happens when I get to the end of
the stream and I've read some bytes but not
enough to fill up the entire 512 bits to use
a compression on it?
Well then we use this finalize method to basically
pad the end.
What we have to do is we append one bit onto
the end of the message and then we pad it
with zeros.
In all cases we're going to pad with zeros
and append the length of the message that
we just read as a 64-bit integer on to the
end of the message,
but if adding that length on to the end is
going to overflow the block size, then we
actually need to do an extra compression.
So we might have to add on more zeros, compress,
and then add on the length, but in any case
we're basically just padding with exactly
enough zeroes so that once we get to the end
of the message,
we can add on our one bit, our zero padding,
and then our bytes representing the length
so that it comes out exactly to a multiple
of 512 bits, and we do one last compression.
Once we finalize the message then we just
need to output the digest or hex digest and
the way this works is it's literally just
the state variables, whatever we updated them
to,
that's now what we output as the digest.
So why do we say that md5 is a completely
broken hash function at least for cryptographic
purposes?
Well it's susceptible to a number of attacks
and, for one, here is a collision.
Here's two different messages that have the
exact same md5 hash.
I know they look very very similar, and they
are, but they actually differ in two places:
there is 0x00 0x02 and 0x55 versus 0x55.
They're a bunch of different types of attacks
against hash algorithms.
If you say you have a collision attack against
a hashing algorithm, then you're just saying
you're in the situation like I showed before
with these two messages,
where are you just have two different messages
that have the same hash.
And that's not necessarily that useful for
an exploit.
What would be more useful to an attacker is
something like a chosen prefix attack.
It's given this name because you can pick
any two prefixes you want like this one says
"launch the nukes" and this one says "don't
launch the nukes" and then you can add on
extra bytes, different sets of bytes to those
two messages, and then whatever suffix you
want after that, such that those two things
have the same hash.
Already in the real world there have been
several instances where either researchers
or real hackers were able to use something
like a chosen prefix attack on md5.
One instance they had a Microsoft code signature
for one of their binaries and they had Microsoft
sign something that was completely innocuous,
but that completely innocuous thing had the
same md5 hash as a virus.
So whenever you're allowed to control the
prefixes like that, that's the case where
you can really start doing some damage.
Okay so these last two attacks are just theoretical
for md5, there's no publicly known actual
implementation that can do either of these
things.
So a second pre-image attack is basically,
you have a file or message that already exists
and you want to find another message with
the same hash.
You can imagine, you have an operating system
a Linux image that lots of people are downloading,
and hacker could switch it out for a different
image that has the same hash.
And a full preimage attack is basically the
same thing but you don't even need the file,
all you need is the hash of the file.
And that's all I've got, thanks for making
it to the end, don't forget to like, comment,
subscribe, and check out our sponsor in the
link below.